hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outboard and the villains
continue to Rampage across the
battlefields and the heroes and heroes
students are fighting for their lives
shigaraki is seemingly back at full
power his ability to use quirks restored
Deku is so tired that he's struggling to
breathe and Sad Man's parade just keeps
getting sadder for the heroes but there
is one small bit of good news for the
heroes there is one tiny but important
Ray of Hope in the darkness and this one
thing could change everything in the
final battle so let's get into it you
guys know the drill if you enjoy our mha
content and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now it only takes you a second but
it really helps us with that YouTube
algorithm and a quick reminder that over
half of you guys who watch our videos
are not yet subscribed subscribing is
completely free and it is a very real
way of directly supporting the channel
so do me a favor and do it right now
finally this video will of course
contain Boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned so in the previous chapter
we saw that the heroes and hero students
at gunga Mountain were stuck between a
rock and a hard place they found
themselves between Dobby's deadly blue
flames and an army of twice clones
created by toga when she initiated Sad
Man's parade the heroes were trying to
retreat and escape the Carnage as best
they could but it wasn't looking good
all for one tried to use the chaos on
the battlefield to escape and get to
shigaraki but he was stopped by hawks
despite already being injured Hawks
decided to do whatever it took to stop
all for one from joining up with
shigaraki Hawks could sense that there
is a good re reason why all for one
needs to get to shigaraki and Hawks
believes that if he can stop this
reunion from happening the heroes will
likely have a much better chance of
winning in the end since Hawks is
already injured and exhausted he knows
full well that he is risking his life by
confronting all for one but he believes
that it's worth it if he can stall all
for one for long enough he might give
the heroes a UA a fighting chance
against shigaraki and even if Hawks has
to pay for this with his life he is
happy to pay the price Hawks has always
been the type of hero who knows what has
to be done and who is willing to do what
it takes if he has to take the life of
another or even give up his own life
Hawks is willing to make that sacrifice
and this is what makes him such an
interesting and memorable Hero at the
end of the previous chapter the big
final battle between Dobby and Endeavor
had just been and set up but before that
fight can really begin the latest
chapter moves us away from the battle on
gunga mountain and brings us back to
Deku shigaraki and the others at UA the
new chapter also continues with the
theme of the previous few chapters which
is the fact that the hero's strategy for
dividing the villains has failed the
villains managed to completely turn the
tables on the heroes and at this moment
they seem to have a decisive advantage
on the battlefield however there is one
tiny sliver of Hope left for Deku and
the heroes back at the UA we see the
newly opened portal that first appeared
at the end of chapter
374. izava sees present Mike and
kurogiri emerging from the portal and he
knows right away that this isn't good
moments later one of the twice clones
also emerges from the portal and rushes
at isawa monama and Manuel this clone
then begins to multiply and in a matter
of seconds the heroes are badly
outnumbered aizawa and manual attempt to
beat the Clones back but there are just
too many of them and the Clones managed
to tackle monama to the ground in that
moment monoma breaks eye contact with
shigaraki and then in the very next
moment a giant explosion rocks the UA
grounds those power poles that had been
keeping the UA afloat and the force
field in effect crumble into pieces and
suddenly the UA building begins losing
altitude with so much damage to the
power grid the UA can't stay afloat
anymore and so all the heroes and hero
students who have been giving it their
all to maintain the Integrity of the
floating UA are desperately trying to
figure out what to do now now there is
some confusion with the translations but
to me it seems like the sudden failure
of the UA system is the result of
Skeptics hacking effort at first I was
thinking that maybe shigaraki had used
some sort of explosive Quirk as soon as
monoma broke eye contact with him but
the chapter seems to be implying that
Skeptics hacking is at least partially
to blame for what's going on and not
only has skeptic been able to gain
control over the UA system but he has
also gained control over the underground
shelters where all the civilians are
still hiding needless to say things are
not looking very daijoubu for the heroes
but that is when the heroes find a small
Ray of Hope as the epic battle between
Deku and shigaraki escalates
shigaraki the real tomurashigaraki
suddenly reappears he sheds those
strange finger mutations from his body
almost like a snake shedding its skin
and he then returns to his normal slim
four by slim I mean he still has muscles
but he's not like this grotesque bulge
of different fingers that are all over
his body shigaraki then asks Deku why he
wanted to know whether he shigaraki was
still in there inside his own body he
tells Deku that his attempts to
communicate with him are pointless
because Deku is a hero and shigaraki is
his villain but this brief exchange
reveals a crucial piece of information
to Deku tomura shigaraki AKA tenko
shimura is indeed still there in fact
not only is he still there but he is
actually able to somehow regain control
from all for one and even though
shigaraki himself is certainly no Ally
to the heroes the fact that his
personality is able to return confirms
that all for one still hasn't managed to
gain complete control over his new
vessel the heroes still have a chance to
foil all for one's plans and prevent him
from turning shigaraki's body into the
perfect new vessel for himself that said
the path for bringing all for one down
is not going to be an easy one
especially since shigaraki himself is a
villain through and through even if the
heroes can prevent all for one from
taking over shigaraki's body they will
still have to defeat tomurashigaraki
himself that is challenging enough all
on its own but to make things worse Deku
is starting to feel the strain from
overusing his newest Quirk gear shift
he's feeling tired and he's worried that
if he doesn't let his body rest he soon
won't even have enough energy to breathe
on his own but the second user of one
for all and the original user of gear
shift seems to be telling Deku that they
can't quit just yet through the
mysterious connection between all for
one and one for all the second user
seems to confirm that all for one still
doesn't have the ability to control
shigaraki's body there is still a chance
that the heroes can take shigaraki out
before All For One turns him into a
perfect vessel for his own Evil
Personality but time is running out and
Deku has to move now there is no time to
rest or think things through it's time
to act as skeptic continues hacking and
interfering with the UA system he is
shocked to hear someone say found you
this voice is coming from one of his own
computer screens and it says that
finding skeptic was difficult but she
was still able to do it for gentle's
sake the final Page Reveals that best
girl La Brava is back only this time she
is not working against the authorities
she is working with them her
counter-attack against Skeptics hacking
is being actively supervised by
detective tsukauchi and that is how this
chapter ends and there are some big big
takeaways from this chapter that we
simply cannot ignore first the villains
are definitely winning right now and the
heroes are likely to take some serious
damage and maybe even suffer some
serious casualties that's because the
villains are just so freaking strong
right now they got Dobby going berserk
they got toga using Sad Man's parade
they got Primal for one and they got
shigaraki all of these guys are absolute
monsters and on top of that Deku is
running out of steam so we're about to
witness a very tough period for the
heroes the good news for the heroes is
that there is still time to stop all for
one from taking complete control of
shigaraki but with shigaraki now
presumably being able to use his quirks
again again and with Deku clearly tired
from using gear shift how are the heroes
going to stop shigaraki before all for
one arrives personally I really enjoyed
the return of La Brava she's a really
cool and memorable character and
bringing her in to virtually Flex on
skeptic was a great idea frankly I hope
we get to see more epic character
returns soon I've been waiting so long
to see stain fighting alongside Deku
against the villains I thought we were
gonna get that during deku's little
vigilante Arc but sadly we didn't I'm
still hoping that we will get to see
something like this in the future
because stain's character Arc clearly
isn't over yet and he still has a lot
that he could contribute to the story
but now let's talk about the secret
connection between all for one and one
for all and how this connection might
affect the final battle we know that all
for one was actually used to create one
for all in the first place and the two
quirks are originally belonged to Two
Brothers so there is clearly an
important connection between them but
the second user seems to be hinting at
an even closer connection and this is
something that we got a preview of
during the climax of The jakku Arc the
second user's Vestige seems to be able
to sense who is really in control of
shigaraki's body and of The Quirk all
for one itself this focus on the
connection between all for one and one
for all tells me that we are about to
see a showdown in the Vestige world at
some point in this final Arc while those
main fights continue to rage outside we
may also get an internal Battle of the
vestiges in the Vestige world that the
two quirks have created that is an
entirely new Battlefield that could be
introduced into the story very soon and
this Vestige Battlefield would feature
characters who have been long dead like
Nana and all the previous users of one
for all actively fighting against the
vestiges of all for one and shigaraki as
those guys attempt to steal one for all
from Deku this internal struggle will be
especially important given what we just
learned about Deku and how he's
struggling just to keep breathing after
seemingly overusing his newest Quirk
gear shift is Deku pushing himself too
far and is he actually tearing himself
apart from the inside because of his
desire to defeat the villains and
protect everyone is the connection
between all for one and one for all
going to get stronger during the final
fight which will allow both Deku and
shigaraki to access the Vestige world
and engage in battle on yet another
front how will the already exhausted
deck who deal with shigaraki who now
presumably has full access to all his
quirks once again will deku's body be
forced to evolve and attain Quirk
Singularity as I have theorized in the
past these are the big questions that I
am wondering about as we wait for the
next Shout after to drop happy New Years
everyone I appreciate you watching our
stuff and don't miss this other video
about how strong full power shigaraki
really is link is on screen right now
and down in the description